[Música]
es un tres mástiles que parece salido
directamente del siglo 18 la hermione la
réplica de la fragata del marqués de
lafayette desde su lanzamiento en 2014
el buque ha recorrido 22.000 millas
náuticas es decir 40.000 kilómetros
este excepcional barco cuenta con una
tripulación atípica a bordo cuando coupé
[Música]
marinos profesionales supervisan a unos
60 jóvenes marineros que habrán pagado
850 euros cada uno para salir de
información para la invitación a dos
horas de software de mac o que sí y cada
vez que les mientan un nuevo equipo sube
a bordo
navegará por primera vez pero sabe que
las pocas horas de sueño cuenta
sí es importante prepararlo bien como un
pequeño anillo de corredor durante dos
semanas todos tenemos derecho a un
maletero de 100 litros como este así que
hay tienes va a servir
una vez instalados los marineros se
distribuyen equipos para protegerse en
caso del mal tiempo
pantalones etc
[Música]
los marineros están ansiosos por irse
saben que van a vivir una aventura
extraordinaria
y bueno aquí estamos es el comienzo de
15 días en el mar y tenemos que estar es
cubierta
una vez de software psoe le pongo
en la parte trasera de la nave el
comandante de la reunión nos muestra su
camarote la copia exacta del camarote
del marqués de lafayette
así que aquí estamos en el capital
porque era bastante espartano ya que el
espacio a bordo tenía un pequeño mueble
el mínimo aquí para guardar algunas 20
en 1780 lafayette cruzó el atlántico a
bordo de la hermione para apoyar a los
insurgentes estadounidenses que luchaban
por su independencia tres siglos después
la hermione vuelve a soltar amarras
la fragata hará varias paradas frente a
bretaña
[Música]
un lic
para los navegantes voluntarios comienza
la aventura
sí
y me por esto es guapa kutz
en alta mar las condiciones de
navegación pueden cambiar bruscamente
el mar es cada vez más profundo
rápidamente hay que subir al mástil de
más de 25 metros de altura hay una
veintena de ellos en el astillero para
tensar la vela mayor
no debe ser atrapado por el viento ya
que puede rasgarse
maniobras a menudo acrobáticas y
agotadoras
este es el propósito de este viaje poner
a prueba la tripulación sus reacciones
su resistencia
los marineros permanecerán allá arriba
durante más de una hora y media
lo más difícil es miren el estado de mis
manos sujetar la vela la luna se ha
vuelto muy muy dura muy áspera muy
pesada
se necesitan nada menos que cuatro
marineros para tomar el timón
pero algunas personas no se libran del
mareo
[Música]
de repente delfines
los marineros dicen que anuncian el
regreso del buen tiempo
[Música]
la fragata hermione vuelve a navegar en
condiciones mar ideales para el
comandante la réplica de la fragata de
lafayette no tiene nada que envidiarle
al barco original es un velero
excepcional de los que se ven las veces
ya vemos hay una estabilidad de rumbo a
más de 7 nudos 5 con este bien sin que
nada cáncer es muy rápido
una actuación digna de este barco
excepcional se tardó nada menos que 17
años en completarlo una loca apuesta
lanzada por un puñado de entusiastas de
la historia marítima
la ambición construir un barco
utilizando las mismas técnicas y
materiales que en el siglo 18 en total
este titánico proyecto habrá costado
unos 25 millones de euros financiados
principalmente con fondos públicos
fin de la jornada para los marineros la
fragata echar el ancla en la bahía de tu
acné
muy
durante unas horas los marineros podrán
descansar y relajarse
por la noche en cubierta sonrisas y
camaradería
juntos han resistido la tormenta desde
2014 se han formado más de 500 marineros
a bordo de la nave
[Música]
y